so I've been informed about a couple of
things this week that have really been
bothering me and I thought that I wasn't
sure what to do about it I've been
communicating with some of my friends
and colleagues about it but that wasn't
enough so I thought I'd try to write my
thoughts down and then talk about them a
little bit and see where I got with that
so I've entitled this talk professor
against political correctness and the
reason for that is because it's blunt
and to the point I'm very concerned
about what's happening in the
universities it's not so bad in Canada
I've been fortunate very fortunate at
the University of Toronto but there are
continually things happening including
in the administration here and in the
broader political world that make me
very nervous I like to attribute that to
the fact that I know something about the
way that totalitarian and authoritarian
political states develop and I can't
help but think that I'm seeing a fair
bit of that right now so I guess I also
wanted to do this because there's a
misapprehension that everyone in
academia is politically correct and
that's is true very frequently among
social scientists about 20 percent of
whom identify themselves as Marxists
which in my estimation by the way is no
better than identifying as Nazis given
the murderous nough some arcs is
doctrine and the fact that we know how
it's turned out when implemented in
multiple countries now but I'm not
politically correct and I want to talk
to you today about why all this worries
me so I got wind of two events this week
one actually dates from last May there
is a legislation passed or the first
reading of legislation in the federal
house set in Canada about a bill called
c16 which was in
is an attempt to alter the Canadian bill
of Human Rights it's tangled up with
another organization that operates at a
provincial level in Canada in Ontario
which is the province I reside in called
the Ontario Human Rights Commission and
as far as I can tell what happens at the
Ontario Human Rights Commission is
rapidly turned into policy in multiple
provinces across Canada and perhaps
increasingly at the federal level
there's a Liberal government in power
that's the name of the political party
in Ontario and now there's a Liberal
government federally and there is
obviously a fair bit of cross influence
for better for worse also this week I
got wind of a University of Toronto
human resources initiative that also
upset me I guess we could say quite
profoundly and so I thought I'd talk
about all of those and try to see if I
can make some sense out of them
you
so I've I'm making this video because I
don't really know what else to do
I've talked to some colleagues and I've
talked to some colleagues as I or some
some some people inside the university
and outside the university that I know
and they're upset and worried about this
but unclear about what to do and all of
this scares me I guess and here's why
I'm the law the changes to the law scare
me because they they put into the legal
substructure of the culture certain
assumptions about basic human nature
that not only do I believe to be untrue
I think they're also dangerous and
ideologically motivated I also don't
think that the reason for the legal
changes is the stated reason the laws
scare me the doctrines behind the laws
scare me and you know when they're when
there's a law there's a body of thought
that's associated with an a body of
interpretations that are associated with
it that flesh out the law because the
law is a pretty bare thing and I've read
I wouldn't say extensively because
extensively is a lot but I've read
enough about the doctrines behind the
laws so that that has also make also
makes me very nervous
increasingly I see that these more
radical ideas the ideas that we're going
to discuss are bought in people buy in
at the administrative level in large
organizations corporate governmental it
doesn't matter it as long as the
organization is large there's increasing
administrative buy and a lot of this
seems to me to be driven by human
resources departments which I think are
generally the most pathological elements
of large organizations and I say that
because if I've actually had fairly
extensive experience dealing with human
resources departments
I think HR training is very politically
correct like many disciplines we'll talk
about that later the people behind the
doctrines also scare me I think that
generally they're a very bad combination
of resentful
uninformed and that's good enough
resentful and uninformed that's good
enough I also think that their aims are
destructive we rather than constructive
they claim constructive aims but of
course everyone claims constructive aims
but the actions that I see undertaken
seem to be to be driven by resentment
and primarily by resentment and and so I
did I doubt the validity of the claims
the claims are always for equality and
diversity and that kind of thing and
those words are very easy to say but a
lot harder to put into practice so I'm
scared by the people behind the
doctrines I'm scared by the response of
my colleagues at the University a number
of them are unnerved by the continual
move towards political correctness and
I'm going to tell you a couple of
responses that I've got recently from
people that I think are quite brave by
the way but worried about making a
statement putting their careers on their
line worried about being tortured to
death by people on line worried about
administrative over response or even
administrative response worried well
here's why the things that I'm seeing at
work will have to be discussed in a
phone conversation this is a professor
an American professor I asked how this
person was feeling about the position
that they held at the University the
person said the thing that I'm seeing at
work will have to be discussed in a
phone conversation it's hard for me
personally to explain it in email I'm
not certain
this is the career path I'm interested
in anymore I actually find myself
sensory things censoring things that I'd
normally say to students and I'm not
sure how to stop that self censorship
the censorship leads to me not truly
educating them in a manner that will let
me feel like I've done my job well it's
not as much from the administration yet
as it is from the students see I don't
see that so much at the University of
Toronto the students here are so
terrified of the job market and
generally speaking so diligent
conscientious that they are not
particularly sidetracked by
political correctness so but that's
obviously not my colleagues experience
in the US this is in California another
colleague this is more local said
something I thought was very intelligent
I think that's why this sort of thing is
so difficult to stand up to the personal
consequences of objecting are huge and
this person is referring to the
possibility of adverse job effects I
guess effects unemployment and you think
tenure would protect people against that
and I suppose it probably does but it's
that doesn't mean that people are
necessarily willing to put it to the
test
and they're worried about being
pilloried online by social justice
warriors and and and and so on and
having the reputation savaged and
demolished so you know I'm not that's a
good that's a good that's a reasonable
fear especially given the next part
which is the effect of my objection on
society will be minuscule so there's
this combination that's the idea anyways
the personal consequences of JEP
objecting are potentially huge in that
the social effects are miniscule
there'll be no positive effect and so
the the thinking goes why put yourself
and potentially your family and your
financial stability and all about at
risk by speaking out when the
consequences will be will be minimal and
you know I've talked to other people
outside of academia academia writers for
example who've had friends who've made a
comment online you know which they
thought was rather innocuous that's
quoted over and over again and some some
times in major newspapers as you know
emblematic of their particular stance
and that shows them in a very harsh
light so anyways this particular
colleague concluded by saying we should
have acted 10 years ago well you know I
feel for both of these colleagues I
think they're both excellent educators
by the way and they're also I would say
classically liberal people you know
they're not they're not you you wouldn't
call them conservatives you certainly
wouldn't call them right-wingers they're
people
their concerns aren't driven by their
political ideologies it's as simple as
that their concerns are driven by their
by their continual observations
increasingly continual observations that
things are not going in the proper
direction in universities and that it's
becoming increasingly difficult for
professors and and students for that
matter at least of a particular kind of
political orientation to even have the
opportunity to say what they think so
okay so that scares me it scares me when
I see we'd decent people and I think
people who are more courageous than
average frightened into submission and
considering altering their career paths
because they don't feel that they can
say what they think anymore and they're
afraid of the direction that the
universities are going so yeah that's
scary so then I'm I'm a clinical
psychologist this is starting to affect
my clients I've had three clients in the
last two years who have been and who
have been driven near the point of
insanity by politically correct
occurrences at work one of them was a
bank employee what what finally did her
in fundamentally was she sent me a very
long email chain referring to a series
of discussions that happened in in this
Bank internally about whether or not the
word flipchart you know referring to
those large pads of paper that you put
up on a stand that you can flip forward
and draw on kind of an archaic
technology now whether or not the word
flip chart was pejorative and racist and
the reason for that was that apparently
the word flip can be used pejoratively
to refer to filipinos which is something
I didn't even know and I suppose a
Filipino could conceivably take offense
to having a pad of paper named flipchart
although it's hard to imagine the
circumstances under which that might
arise or at least once it was hard to
imagine
anyways she gave me access to a string
of email conversations about that
particular topic and the bank did
eventually agree to stop using the term
flipchart I don't know what they
replaced it with but you know she was a
very very sensible person an immigrant
by the way who couldn't reconcile her
requirement
you know her moral requirement to work
hard and be productive and be sensible
and be conscientious with the fact that
people were being called oh called on to
alter their behavior in ways that were
absolutely nonsensical and she was from
an Eastern European country and of
course for her this was reminiscent of
the tactics of the worst of the
ideologues in the 1970s and 80s and
before that so it was very very hard on
her she she was very very stressed by
the situation at work and then I had
another client who worked in an HR
department in a major educational
institute and he was always being called
on to manifest his support for various
feminist initiatives at the educational
institute and he wasn't really all that
comfortable presenting himself as a pro
feminist because he actually wasn't one
and you can argue one way or another
about the propriety of that and that's
really not my point my point is is that
he believed and I think with cause that
his job would have been in jeopardy if
he would have let his objections to the
demands of the political environment
within the workplace if he would have
made those objections known and and I
would say he's he's a little bit more he
was a little bit more to the right than
most of the people that that I've talked
with but not to any great degree
although like many people I think he's
being driven in that direction by the
continual radical moves to the left that
seemed to be part and parcel of every
organization in in in maybe in modern
Western society now
and then the other client that I had who
was very much troubled by this was a
social worker who was was I think she
was she was she was a immigrant as well
quite conservative from she was from a
conservative culture and was very much
they had very much difficulty with the
demands for example that she allow non
surgically altered transsexual men free
access to the women's shelters and the
women's shelters for example here are
some of the people in them obviously say
or Muslim women who come from very
conservative cultures who really can't
even function in a situation where you
know a male biological male has been
given access to what in principle is
supposed to be a woman's shelter and and
that was one of many things that that
bothered her but we don't need to get
into that the point is is that I've had
people who've been driven to seek
psychological counseling because of the
effect of politically correct oppression
on them in the workplace and so that's
worrisome so that's a whole bunch of
things that make me nervous
and then my own response scares me I
find this stuff maddening I can't really
believe the amount of foolishness that
that that that that has accumulated
around these rather contentious Marxist
semi Marxist political issues which I
have which I don't I have no respect for
as I said already I think that Marxism
and Neel Marxism is no better than
fascism and neo-fascism I think the
historical evidence for that is
absolutely clear I can't understand why
we think it's acceptable for academics
and their followers to call themselves
Marxist to the neo-marxists but we we
would we we would not for a second
countenance the same thing from the
fascists in the neo-fascists
anyways the upside of it is is that I'm
nervous about doing this lecture and
I've also become nervous about some of
the things that I'm teaching which i
think and I'm going to discuss this a
little bit further or look further on in
this in this discussion I think that
some of the things that I say in my
lectures now might be illegal I think
they might even be I think that they
might even be sufficient to me to be for
me to be brought before the Ontario
Human Rights Commission under their
amended hate speech laws and that scares
me as well and it scares me that I think
that because it sounds paranoid but most
of the time in the past when I've been
concerned that the that something is
going to happen at an administrative or
bureaucratic level at the university
that it's it's frequently the case that
when I'm worried about something
happening that it does actually happen
and that it's not so much worry as an
ability to see high probability outcomes
down into the future so and you know
even if even if the things that I'm
saying are haven't been made illegal or
you know heaven forbid transformed into
suddenly into hate speech I am nervous
that they might be and even that's
making it more difficult for me to teach
because in order for me to teach I have
to say what I think is true and I can't
do that if I'm afraid if I have to be
afraid of the consequences I'll stop
talking you know even oh if you can say
one thing or the other and there's a lot
of pressure not to say the first thing
and you could just as easily say the
second thing it's just as easy to say
the second thing why not just not bother
with it you know well the reason I can't
do that is because if I have something
to say and I don't say it then it drives
me crazy and so and that's not something
I'm willing to I'm not willing to go
down that path and I've already decided
that I'm going to try to tell people
what I think and and to tell them what I
think to be the truth even though it's
the truth that I think that I'm not
saying that what I think is true I mean
who knows what's true that's why we have
freedom of speech right to sort out
what's true so but I can tell you that
it's true that I'm scared about this and
I think that's appalling I really think
that's appalling all right so this is
Bill c16 and and somebody sent this to
me this week and pointing out what was
happening with regards to this
fundamental Canadian human rights
legislation and I'm going to do a bad
job of this because it take it takes
more time than I have to do this
properly so all I can do is tell you my
initial thoughts and try to justify them
as best I can
it would take months to do this lecture
properly and I haven't got months to do
it property so I'm going to have to do
it badly so here we go so bill c16 is an
act to amend the Canadian Human Rights
Act in the Criminal Code so these are
major this is a major Amendment because
the Human Rights Act and the Criminal
Code are major pieces of legislation
they affect everyone and the
consequences for contravening them are
severe as severe as severe consequences
can be short of you know of illness and
death so they're non-trivial pieces of
legislation now if you guys aren't in
Canada you might wonder why you should
care about this but what's happening in
Canada is happening throughout the West
so I'm going to concentrate on the local
occurrences but you can think you can be
sure they're emblematic of similar
things happening in your jurisdictions
so because this is certainly not only a
Canadian problem and in fact I would say
to to some fairly large degree Canada
has been reasonably free of this
especially at the university level and
and it's almost as if we're importing it
unnecessarily but ok this enactment
amends the Canadian Human Rights Act to
add gender identity and gender
expression to the list of prohibited
grounds of discrimination now this
amendment has only gone through first
reading this was back in May but similar
legislation has already been passed in a
number of provinces those are the
smaller like this they're like states
they're the smaller subdivisions of the
Canadian political system so
this hasn't been made into law federally
but it it's it's likely going to and it
already has at the provincial level as I
said so this enactment also amends the
Criminal Code to extend the protection
against hate propaganda set out in that
act to any section of the public that is
distinguished by gender identity or
expression and to clearly set out that
evidence that an offense was motivated
by bias prejudice or hate based on
gender identity or expression
constitutes an aggravating circumstance
that a court must take into
consideration when it imposes a sentence
okay so that's basically a hate crime
modification so if you commit a crime
well that's one thing but if you commit
a crime and it's motivated by bias
prejudice or hate based on age sex race
ethnic identity and so so and other
things including now gender identity or
expression then that makes the crime
worse it falls into the category of hate
crime and so that's what this
modification is intended to produce or
to bring about so any any crime that is
associated with bias prejudice or hate
based on gender identity or expression
is now an aggravating circumstance okay
so so it's a hate crime now I have some
real problems with hate speech
legislation and the reason I have
problems with it is that it's not
obvious wind' speech is motivated by
hate angry speech can feel like it's
motivated by hate but angry speech is
the only kind of speech in some sense
that is indicative of real disagreement
I mean I'm not saying that all
disagreement should be angry I'm just
saying that if there is real
disagreement the it's all anger is often
the evidence for the existence of real
disagreement and if there's real
disagreement angry people have to talk
it out because if they don't then well
then a bunch of terrible things happen
first of all
you start losing track of who the angry
people are second they don't get to say
what's on their mind and even listen to
themselves they don't get to have other
people tell them that they're wrong they
don't get to modify their viewpoints
because talking is thinking you know and
if you start people from talking then
you stop them from thinking and that's a
really bad thing and then if you if you
if you interpret hate speech too broadly
then you drive the so called haters
underground and then you don't know what
they're up to and when people go
underground that isn't good that that's
really not good you get the rise of all
sorts of underground political movements
when people aren't able to express what
they think even though it's unpleasant
so if you want to know where the haters
are then you have to let them talk you
know we even tell two-year-olds who are
angry we say well use your words and the
reason we tell two-year-olds that is
because the alternative to using your
words is using your fists and so if we
don't let angry people talk then the
only they only have to two alternatives
well apart from changing their mind and
they're not going to change their mind
just if you just shut someone up that
doesn't change their mind because partly
the way you change your mind is by
talking and thinking and communicating
with other people and if you shut that
Avenue off for people then they can't
change their minds well then they either
they pull it in and get resentful you
know that's one option they don't take
any action or they get aggressive and
violent or they start agitating for
violence and so you know I can't help
but think that well there's a famous
psychoanalytic psychoanalytic dictum if
you don't understand the motivation for
something look at the outcome and infer
the motivation well if the outcome of
shutting people up is that they get
violent then it's hard for me to
suppress the suspicion that it was the
incitement of violence that was at least
part of the initial motivation for for
producing the restriction now I think
there's a lot more to it than that you
know I think a lot of it is a lot of
this desire for people not to ever say
anything upsetting is
actually a consequence of trait
agreeableness which is a big five
psychological trait and really agreeable
people are egalitarian by nature but
they also don't like conflict and but
what that means is they don't like
short-term conflict you know they don't
like anybody to be upset and the problem
is sometimes you have to be upset in the
present to solve problems in the medium
and the long term you know you can't
stop people from talking about upsetting
things because as I said that's just the
same as stopping them from thinking and
and if they can't think really
complicated things through well then
they don't solve problems and then the
problems manifest themselves in the real
world it's no joke so there's a recent
case of Lionel Shriver who's a who's a
well I won't talk about her you can look
her up I'll try to stick to the point
here so this is also part of Bill c16
this is modification of section two of
the Canadian Human Rights Act purpose
the purpose of this act is to extend the
laws in Canada to give effect within the
purview of matters coming within the
legislative authority of Parliament
that's Canada's highest governing body
the principle that all individuals
should have an opportunity equal with
other individuals to make for themselves
the lives that they are able and wish to
have and to have their needs
accommodated consistent with their
duties and obligations as members of
society without being hindered in or
prevented from doing so by
discriminatory practices based on race
national or ethnic origin color religion
age sex sexual orientation and now
hypothetically gender identity or
expression marital status family status
disability or conviction for an offense
for which a pardon has been granted or
in respect of which a record suspension
has been ordered okay so well what's
problematic about this
well I've outlined some of it in yellow
I don't really like the idea of wish to
have the lives that they're able and
wish to have and then to have their
needs accommodated
well it's messy it's messy terminology
it's not easy to delineate needs there's
an infinite number of them it's very
very difficult to determine whose needs
should take priority in fact that's why
we have a free-market society we have a
free-market society so that people's
needs can be voted on in some sense by
the purchasing power of free individuals
so that nobody no central committee no
governing body has to decide whose needs
should be accommodated
it's an infinitely complex problem and
it can't be solved by Fiat it's not
possible and this was happened in places
like the so this this was attempted in
places like the Soviet Union where need
decisions were constantly made by
centralized committees and the
consequence was absolutely catastrophic
not only was it economically suicidal it
was also murderous so the whole idea of
having needs accommodated is a very very
it's a very very slippery idea and it
sounds good but it's very very dangerous
it's dangerous because the question who
decides whose needs are paramount is the
crucial question and how is that it's
answered is the crucial issue and that
can go seriously wrong and then well the
inclusion of gender identity or
expression well will we'll discuss that
momentarily and there's also
modification of section 3 for all
purposes of this act the prohibited
grounds of discrimination are race
national or ethnic origin color religion
age sex sexual orientation and then
again newly gender identity or
expression marital status family status
so this is the criminal code
modification modification of subsection
318 4 where they define an identifiable
group and this is for the purpose of
determining who fundamentally is
uttering hate speech or discriminatory
speech and this includes all the
candidates we already described color
race religion national ethnic origin etc
and includes gender identity or
expression and so well will will
continue to talk about that
and then there's modifications of
subparagraph 718 to a again with regards
to hate crime evidence that the offense
was motivated by bias prejudice or hate
based on race national ethnic origin
language color religion etc including
gender identity expression or any other
simpler similar factor the offense was
motivated by okay so this sort of
legislation has already come into play
in provinces in Canada Alberta British
Columbia Newfoundland and Labrador Nova
Scotia Prince Edward Island and and
Ontario and I'm going to concentrate on
Ontario because I think a lot of this is
emanating from a small coterie of people
behind the Ontario Human Rights
Commission which is a particularly
pathological organization in my
estimation and perhaps the biggest enemy
of freedom currently extent in Canada
and I don't say that lightly so the
reason I think the Ontario Human Rights
Commission is is an emblematic
institution in this regard is partly
because I think that the that social
justice warrior type activists are
over-represented in the current
provincial government Federer the
current liberal provincial government
and I can't help but shake this I can't
help but manifest the suspicion that
that's partly because our current
premier is lesbian in her sexual
preference and that in itself doesn't
bother me one way or another I don't
think it's relevant to the political
discussion except insofar as the LBGT
community has become extraordinarily
good at organizing themselves and has a
fairly pronounced and very very
sophisticated radical fringe and I can't
help but see the hand of that in what
I'm going to read to you and you can
make up your own mind and see if you
think the same thing so the wording on
the Ontario Human Rights Commission with
regards to legislation like Bill c16 is
the same it's identical to that on the
Canadian Department of
i given you the links here and so that's
another indication to me that there's
tremendous crosstalk between these
institutions one at the provincial level
that's the Ontario one and one at the
federal level because the wording is
identical so that's the argument for
overlap and the other thing too with
regards to the LBGT angle on this is
that the wording is identical in many
regards to that that's commonly used by
LBGT activists and so that's why I'm
putting the different organizations
together and as I said before I'm not
saying this is right it's what I've been
able to sort out it's what I've been
able to puzzle out and I'm putting it
forward as an element of discussion okay
so here are some of the definitions that
they use and these are now explicit
categories and implicit presumptions of
our most fundamental legal structures so
now these have become something these
definitions have become something more
than fact they've become facts that you
question at your legal peril so here's
the first one gender identity this is
directly from the Ontario Human Resource
Human Rights Commission website gender
identity is each person's internal and
individual experience of gender it is
their sense of being a woman a man both
neither or anywhere along the gender
spectrum now I'd also like to point out
that that's relatively this is a petty
thing to say I suppose but one of the
things that struck me about the Ontario
Human Rights Commission website is that
it's fairly poor very poorly written and
this particular sentence is very poorly
written and policy that's on its way to
be transformed into legislation should
not be poorly written because it means
it's being poorly thought through and
poorly specified and it means that the
people who are doing it aren't being
careful and that makes me nervous and so
then there's things in here that I don't
believe to be true gender identity is
each person's sense of being a woman a
man both neither or anywhere along the
gender spectrum
I don't know what neither means because
I don't know what the options are if
you're not a man or a woman it's not
obvious to me how you can be both
because those are by definition binary
categories there's an idea that there's
a gender spectrum but I don't think that
that's a valid idea I don't think
there's any evidence for it
biological sexuality is ancient it's
hundreds of millions of years old and
it's binary because there's two forms of
of biological sex now of course this is
predicated on the idea that your gender
is somehow independent from your from
your biological sex but that's a
proposition not a fact and even if it's
true it's even if it even if it in some
manner was determined to be true it is
certainly not determined to be true to
that degree now and certainly not to the
degree that it should be instantiated in
law at most it's an opinion and I think
it's an ill informed opinion I think
it's a politically motivated an ill
informed opinion and now it's got the
force of law and then there's another
modification which is gender expression
which is something different than gender
identity so I guess there's biological
sex and then on top of that there's
gender identity which is separate
they're not even correlated they're they
don't bear one or any relationship to
one another I guess one is choice or it
isn't exactly clear I mean here's one of
the things I find very confusing it
seems to me that the leftist activists
have made the claim that with regards to
transsexual individuals for example that
you can be a man in a woman's body and
that that's a biological reality or that
you can be a woman in a man's body and
that's a biological reality so as long
as your gender identity is opposite to
that of your biological Cardinal
biological sexual attributes then that's
biologically determined but if your
gender identity is in sync with your
biological attributes then that's
a free-floating cultural construct
unless I've got my logic wrong somehow
and I cannot see how both of those
things can possibly be true but I don't
think that coherence is one of the
hallmarks of radical politically correct
thinking and you can tell that because
politically correct people like the
people who have produced this
legislation and these policies are
capable of saying things like it is
their sense meaning each person's by the
way it is their sense of being maybe
maybe an individual can decide to be a
plurality as well and that's why there
is being used as the pronoun in this
particular sentence although I think the
real reason is is that the person who
wrote this can't write it is their sense
of being a woman a man both neither or
anywhere along the gender spectrum from
my perspective that sentence is entirely
nonsensical and now it's law and then
okay so we've got biological sex we've
got gender identity and then on top of
that we've got gender expression which I
guess is how you express your gender
identity which is separate from your
biological sexual orientation it's the
way people publicly present their gender
it is the presentation of gender through
such aspects as dress hair makeup body
language and voice okay well those are
canonical categories now and it isn't
clear to me because of the legislation
it's possible I believe it's possible
that my commentary on these definitions
is now illegal and that it's also now
potentially classifiable as hate speech
and I would say if that's the case then
like
well it's the sort of thing I'm going to
question and if someone should be put in
jail for questioning now that I
questioning that mmm then I guess I
should be put in jail because I'm going
to continue to question it I think it's
nonsensical I think the formulation is
absurd I think it has no scientific
standing I think it's ideologically
motivated I think it's divisive I think
it's dangerous
it causes chaos it confuses people
there's no upside to it and for any for
every one person that this potential
transformation of legislation is going
to free from oppression it's going to
deftly confuse a hundred more and I say
that is I say that is a clinician with
some experience in this matter more
definitions the code does not define the
grounds of gender identity gender
expression or sex instead the
understanding of these and other related
terms and the implications for the code
that's the Ontario Human Rights Code and
Ontario Human Rights Commission policies
is evolving from tribunal and Court
decisions social science research as
well as self identity in common everyday
use more definitions sex is the
anatomical classification of people as
male female or intersex usually assigned
at birth I should also point out that
the class of a class of intersex is so
rare to be virtually non-existent and it
isn't reasonable to make standard policy
on the basis of extreme exceptions and
the reason for that is that there are
Myriad's millions of extreme exceptions
and it's not possible to constitute a
collective society on the basis of
legislation that's designed for for
exceptions it can't be done by
definition the laws - the law is
fundamentally there to produce a
collective agreement ok back definitions
once again gender identity is each
person's internal and individual
experience of gender we've already said
that a person's gender identity may be
the same or the same as or different
from their birth assigned sex
well that's the theory gender expression
is how a person publicly expresses or
presents their gender well we've covered
that there's another edition here a
person's chosen name and pronoun are
also common ways of expressing gender
others perceive a person's gender
through those attributes well this is
also Ontario Human Rights Commission
policy okay so this is the scenario I've
been running through my head I can
envision a student or a colleague
insisting that I call them using
gender-neutral pronouns ji zhe or zhe
for you Americans G or sharor I think it
is I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
I think it's manipulative I and I don't
I don't um
I don't recognize another person's right
to determine what pronouns I use to
address them I won't do it now again I
think that because of these new laws
these in it that that that my decision
might be illegal and maybe it's even a
decision of hate but I'm not doing it I
think that those gender-neutral pronouns
are politically motivated I think
they're connected to an entire
underground apparatus of political
motivations radical left political
motivations and I think uttering those
words makes me a tool of those
motivations and I'm going to try to be a
tool of my own motivations as clearly as
I can articulate them and not the
mouthpiece of some murderous ideology a
person's gender identity definitions
continued a person's gender identity is
fundamentally different from and not
related to their sexual orientation well
that's rubbish fundamentally because if
you ran a correlation analysis between
gender identity and sexual orientation
the correlation is going to be something
like 0.95 which indicates an almost
perfect correlation for the vast
majority of people gender identity and
sexual orientation are the same thing
and so it is not fundamentally different
from and not related to their sexual
orientation that's just a misstatement
fact perhaps for a minority of people
sometimes their de social but that that
doesn't mean that a gender identity is
fundamentally different from and not
related to sexual orientation it's a
complete miss statement of fact if
there's a correlation of if there's a
correlation of any magnitude between two
things then one is related to another
and when the correlation is just about
perfect well then they are fundamentally
related so so that's another policy
that's based actually on a lie a
misstatement an untruth all right so
trans or transgender is an umbrella term
referring to people with diverse gender
identities and expressions that differ
from stereotypical gender norms it
includes but is not limited to people
who identify as transgender trans woman
trans man transsexual cross dressers or
gender non-conforming gender variant or
genderqueer now here's what I think
about these terms you see the people who
use these terms want everyone to believe
that they're for all the good things
that they say they're for but I don't
believe any of that I don't think that
they're for good things at all I think
that they use the pretense that they're
for good things you know that they stand
for good things to continue their
nefarious activity and one of the most
nefarious elements of their activity is
the use of these ideological clubs you
know when the club basically is here's
the club right I mean the kind of club
that you hit people with if there's a
difference in outcome then it's a
consequent of consequence of racism and
bias and then if I point out the
difference then I'm a good person
so my little routine for wandering
through the world making sure that I'm a
good person unlike those other people
who aren't good people that that need to
be punished and perhaps jailed um I look
for inequalities and wherever I find
them I attribute them to racism and so
that means I can spend my whole life
doing nothing but mmm being on the side
of goodbye ferreting out all the evil
that resides in other people and not in
me I don't trust people like that
think that the continual generation of
these terms is a consequence of the
desire to make that game continue for as
long as possible regardless of the
consequences so that the people who hold
those opinions can always be morally
correct and have a whole set of enemies
to go after and that's why the terms
keep multiplying because every time
Society moves to become more tolerant
more liberal well then that interferes
with the game because the game is well
we have to find racist and horrible
people and so the solution to that is
well let's just continue to generate
categories more and more categories to
demonstrate how unequal people are well
because the categories are infinitely
divisible and we'll get to that later
it's a game that never runs out and if
you're a professional if you're someone
whose profession is to be politically
correct or to be a social justice
warrior and that might be an academic
especially a Marxist one and in all
sorts of sub disciplines we'll also get
to that later like sociology and Social
Work and many of the Social Sciences
apart from those two and and educational
psychology that's another major offender
and social psychology another major
offender then your your publicly
subsidized for your damn viewpoints and
if you can continue to make the case
that the world is full of racist racists
and and people possessed by ethnic
hatred you know persecuting the the poor
minorities that your stick lasts forever
and you can fully justify your you're
subsidized position as well as being on
the side of right and morality and
making the world a better place what a
good deal for everyone who is
politically correct definition of
discrimination and harassment now these
are truly terrifying discrimination
happens when a person experiences
negative treatment or impact intentional
or not because of their gender identity
or gender expression okay and that could
be age sex race etc okay think about
that sentence discrimination happens
when a person experiences negative
treatment or impact okay so let's say
negative impact well so what that means
is that if I say something
that makes you feel negative emotion or
maybe even interferes with your
happiness because those are actually
separate things
then you've experienced negative impact
okay now that okay that's bad enough
because it means that you get to decide
when what I've said is not appropriate
but the worst part of it and that's not
so good because you could misunderstand
me or maybe what I'm saying is right and
you just don't like it or you know
there's a whole variety of reasons you
might get upset about what I say so the
fact that you get upset about something
that's negative impact but that doesn't
necessarily mean that something bad is
how I might even mean that something's
good good has happened I don't think
I've ever learned anything in my entire
life that wasn't preceded by some kind
of negative impact we always learn
things the hard way
but the worst part of it is the next
phrase discrimination happens when a
person experiences negative treatment or
impact intentional or not okay so here
think about this when it when when when
you have little children and maybe one
one runs into the other and knocks
knocks even your child out you set your
child up and the first thing you say is
well Bobby didn't mean it and the reason
you say that is because we've learned
and this is painful this is this is a
painful thing that human beings have
learned it's at the base of our modern
legal systems that intent matters
it isn't consequences that you judge its
intent if I accidentally run into you
that's way different than if I run into
you on purpose you know if I if I if if
I kill you accidentally that's
manslaughter at its worst if I kill you
with intent that's that's that's the
worst form of homicide we judge people
on intent not on consequences and so
this policy is designed to reverse that
it's now possible that you can didn't
discriminate against someone and violate
the law and I think maybe even be
persecuted for hate crimes because this
is written in such a messy manner by
doing something accidental intentional
or not well who's going to judge
that well you can imagine who's going to
judge that the kind of people who would
dare to judge that harassment harassment
is a form of discrimination
it can include sexually explicit or
other inappropriate comments not defined
questions jokes name-calling images
email in social media it doesn't say
what email and social media content just
email in social media which is another
indication of the appalling level of
literacy behind these behind these
statements transphobic homophobic or
other bullying sexual advances touching
another unwelcome and ongoing behavior
that insults demeans harms or threatens
a person in some way alright so the
first thing you might note is that this
has been written to cover the broadest
possible range of possibilities that's
the exact opposite of what good
legislation does so if you combine these
discrimination and harassment that the
policies basically allow for people to
like if I in and if I unintentionally
negatively impact you with a joke then
I'm harassing you and that's well on its
way to being well it's a violation of
the Ontario Human Rights Code it's an
offence according to the Ontario Human
Rights Commission and it's on the way to
being a hate crime as far as I can tell
with the modifications of federal
legislation so and then to cap it all
off they throw this and at the end of
the sentence other unwelcome and ongoing
behavior that insults demeans harms or
threatens a person in some way okay so
that's all pretty scary but then there's
more of course and so this is the
Ontario Human Rights Commission
developing policies on organizational
liability so listen to this
organizations are liable for any
discrimination and harassment that
happens they are also liable for not
accommodating in a trans person needs
unless it would cause undue hardship the
whole issue of undue hardship is a
tricky one because I'm not exactly sure
who adjudicates that in you know
we'll get to that later they must deal
with complaints take steps to prevent
problems and provide a safe welcoming
environment for trans people okay and
and you know old people and and ethnic
ethnically diverse people and you know
differently gendered people and all of
that so fine organizations are liable
for any discrimination and harassment
that happens okay well that puts a hell
of an onus on the organization because
it isn't exactly clear to me how
organizations are going to monitor all
of their people all of the time in the
organizations what if they're using
social media outside the organization so
organizations are now liable for all of
this so how are you going to police all
that okay next more on liability from
the Ontario Human Rights Code under
Section 46.3 of the code a corporation
trade union or occupational association
unincorporated association or employers
organization now listen to this will be
held responsible for discrimination
including acts or omissions committed by
employees or agents in the course of
their employment this is known as
vicarious liability okay responsible
parties violate the code now this is
where it gets this is where it gets
horrible I think where they directly or
indirectly intentionally or
unintentionally infringe the code or
whether they otherwise authorize condone
or adult behavior that is contrary to
the code it is unacceptable to choose to
remain unaware ignore or failed to
address potential or actual human rights
violations whether or not a complaint is
made god you couldn't possibly design a
broader definition of liability
potential or actual human rights
violations whether or not a complaint is
made okay so does that that means that
you have vicarious liability if you fail
to address a potential human rights
violation whether or not a complaint is
made
the only thing I can say about
legislation that's written in this
manner is that it seems to me to be
consciously designed to get as many
people in trouble as possible that's it
it's designed to get as many people as
possible in trouble at the same time so
that brings us to the end of part 1 of
this talk on political correctness in it
I described the increasing fear that's
spread by politically correct activism
throughout large organizations including
academic institutions like the
University of Toronto I also discussed
the increasing all pervasiveness of this
viewpoint because it's not something
that's localized anymore to academic
institutions it's spread beyond them and
is is characteristic of the
preoccupations of a certain kind of
administrator at a very large multitude
of large organizations then I described
in detail the Canadian Bill c16 which is
an attempt to modify the Canadian Human
Rights Code and the Criminal Code to
make a whole variety of speech acts and
the holding of certain opinions or they
articulating of them criminal and maybe
even criminal under the provisions of
the hate of hate crime legislation in
part two I'm going to give you more
detailed analysis of the University of
Toronto's attempts to transform its HR
department into a politically correct
organization I'm using the the goals of
the University of Toronto as a
cautionary tale about how such political
maneuvers operate at a local level again
on the principle that a good story about
something local is a good story about
something with general significance in
part three I'm going to talk about what
individuals can do about these sorts of
things what you as a citizen how you as
a citizen might arm yourself intellect
so that you can articulate a stance
against this kind of movement if you
feel that that's in your best interests
thanks for listening if you want to
support endeavor such of these such as
these please visit my patreon site which
allows you to do so it's a monthly
subscription site that helps me develop
these videos and continue my work on
them and who knows if things keep up the
way they are maybe it will be my own
only source of income after it becomes
impossible for me to work at a
university and say what I want to say if
you want to provide such support just
Google patreon Jordan Peterson thanks a
lot and we'll talk to you very soon